the chief executive of British Airways
owner ihe has said the airline may have
to delay the return of more flights
following the prime minister's statement
speaking to the Transport Select
Committee Willie Walsh said they
proposed 14 day quarantine on
international arrivals would cause more
harm to the already battered industry or
the general secretary briefed airline
pilots association is Brian struttin who
joins us now Brian welcome to you Willie
Walsh is not happy well he's not happy
about this 14 day quarantine proposal
from government I don't think anybody in
the aviation industry is happy about
that it's a real body blow to the
industry which is already reeling from
the loss of revenues because nobody's
flying at the moment and we haven't seen
the details of this proposal we don't
know why it's being introduced now
whereas it hasn't been up till now
nobody knows how it's going to work
nobody knows what other measures are
going to be put in place it's a real
setback for an industry that was already
struggling do you think it's possible
that some of those other measures might
not be used in combination with
isolation but maybe just used in their
own right so for instance you know
reconfiguring the cabin so people are
socially dissidents face masks perhaps
temperature checks well I think there's
a number of things being discussed and
and we haven't had any of the detail of
that shared with us we barely had a
chance to even think about some of these
ideas that the government's been
floating but the point is this they will
all add up to problems for aviation they
will cause delays it'll be reasons for
passengers not to fly that's gonna cause
inefficiencies you've already heard not
just really water people like Michael
O'Leary saying we're not going to fly
inefficiently if the government wants
aviation to get back flying and
government wants to impose restrictions
then government should fund the bill for
that yeah I mean do you think that the
government accepts the argument that
this is a strategic industry if you want
to fly you the best brains from around
the world into the country if you want
to give you tourism sector afloat in the
medium-term people have got to be able
to get here
I'm not convinced that government has
got the message actually you hear the
depart of transport ministers talking
about supporting other parts of the
transport sector but when it comes to
aviation
everything seems to be stacked against
airlines and airports and and flying in
general so I'm not sure government does
get the message it's vitally important
half of our international trade in
Freight goes through Airlines now we
fully pull out a brexit at the end of
this year so coming out of the covert
crisis is one thing are we prepared for
our trade on the world stage without a
viable UK aviation industry no we won't
be and governments really got to get a
grip on this situation or we won't be
able to compete it's as simple as that
Brian can you give us a sense of
conversations perhaps you're having with
your members pilots so we're looking at
this landscape and thinking actually I'm
not sure my career as a pilot has a
long-term future there are structural
changes going on here to the in the very
nature of international aviation which
will be perhaps see out my career so
it's time to look at something else yes
in the past couple of weeks we've had
announcements of 23,000 job losses in
the aviation sector bas announced it
wants to release 1,100 pilots virgin as
has announced a significant number as
well Ryanair talking about job losses
and so will other airlines as well and
yes there will be pilots and also
potential people who want to join the
pilot profession who will be thinking is
this really for me because after all to
train to be a pilot you have to invest a
hundred thousand pounds of your own
money no student loan no other kind of
support and a lot of people are going to
be saying in the future
is this a profession I want to get into
with these risks and and that means that
we will then start to hit shortages it
might seem more right to release some
surplus people now if the airlines are
downsizing but how are they going to
recover from that with the damage that's
being done I think it's a very serious
question indeed and that's why I've been
calling for
to lead an holistic approach for the
whole industry to come out of this
together in a way that suits aviation
and the UK economy
Ryan structures the general secretary of
the British Airline Pilots Association
Brian start and appreciate your time
thanks very much